[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver en ce début d'année 2023
meilleurs vœux à tous alors 20 ans 2022
devient donc à voir 20 ans voilà c'est
le nouveau nom de cette émission en
cette nouvelle année première résolution
de 2023 trouver un nom qui dure un peu
plus qu'un an car nous avons aussi un
peu la flemme de changer de générique
tous les quatre matins et la flemme
justement et oui on commençait à l'année
en fanfare c'est le sujet de cette
émission la crise de démotivation la
grosse fatigue que ressente de nombreux
français et qui dépassent le simple
cadre du dry jannerie et des lendemains
de fait difficile et c'est ce que vous
avez montré dans votre étude Jérémy
Pelletier bonjour bonjour alors vous
avez écrit co-écrit une étude intitulée
grosse fatigue épidémie de flemme avec
Jérôme Fourquet pour l'Ifop et la
Fondation Jean Jaurès dont vous êtes le
directeur général je cite aussi un livre
que vous avez publié en 2021 et qui va
beaucoup nous intéresser et qui
s'intitule La fête est finie aux
éditions de l'Observatoire alors vos
travaux je le précise ils tous les
Français mais nous sur ce plateau on va
s'intéresser à ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement la jeunesse la jeunesse
bien représentée sur ce plateau avec
Davy Beauvois bonjour alors vous avez 22
ans 22 ans aujourd'hui tout à fait je
commence à être en bon anniversaire
merci alors vous avez grandi à Bourges
mais vous vivez depuis 5 ans en banlieue
parisienne vous êtes étudiant en
première année de master de
communication publique et politique vous
êtes actuellement en alternance mais
surtout et bien vous la ressentez vous
cette crise de démotivation cette grosse
fatigue et vous êtes notamment sorti
essorée comme beaucoup d'entre nous de
la pandémie de covid alors à côté de
vous Gwenaëlle Molière bonjour vous avez
vous 19 ans vous habitez à Paris et vous
venez de vous réorienter dans vos études
vous aviez commencé des études en
sciences politiques et vous vous lancez
finalement dans une licence 1 de
littérature à partir de cette année et
vous travaillez en parallèle dans un
restaurant et surtout vous ne vous
reconnaissez absolument pas dans cette
fatigue française et vous allez nous
dire pourquoi et enfin j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir Daphné breton bonjour vous
êtes psychologue du travail et des
organisations vous travaillez à Paris
vous avez ouvert une consultation
spécialisée dans l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de souffrance
psychique ou physique en lien avec leur
situation professionnelle votre regard
va nous être précieux et pour commencer
Jérémy Pelletier on va s'intéresser à
votre étude principale conclusion celle
qui s'applique aux jeunes et pour cela
chacun notre journaliste Mathias
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias bonjour Tom alors on le
sait Mathias depuis la crise sanitaire
la motivation des français est en berne
c'est ce que démontre donc l'étude dont
je parlais à l'instant est-ce que ce
phénomène il est particulièrement
représenté chez les jeunes il semblerait
bien tant puisque dans l'étude que vous
évoquez le postulat de départ est qu'un
Français sur 3 et moins motivé qu'avant
dans ce qu'il fait au quotidien depuis
la crise sanitaire un chiffre qui grimpe
à 40% si on se concentre sur les 25 34
ans autre phénomène observé celui de la
fragilisation mentale ou psychologique
avec une véritable explosion des prises
de rendez-vous chez les psy 40% là aussi
des 25 34 ans disent ne pas se sentir
suffisamment solide mentalement pour
tout affronter dans leur vie quotidienne
dernière statistique cette fois un peu
plus alarmante 20% des 25 34 ans 10
ressentir leur vie de pleurer durant la
journée c'est 6 points de plus que la
moyenne des Français alors comment se
traduit cette perte de motivation que
vous décrivez chez les jeunes de
plusieurs manières prenons le sport par
exemple un grand producteur
d'endorphines c'est bien connu et bien
depuis la crise sanitaire 28% des 18 24
ans disent faire moins d'activités
physiques autre constat similaire avec
le travail regardant ce graphique
illustre l'adhésion à la maxime il faut
souffrir pour réussir 62 % des 65 et
plus adhère à cette idée pour seulement
38% des 18 24 ans un changement du
rapport à l'effort en quelque sorte qui
a ensuite provoqué le mouvement qu'on a
appelé la grande démission et les
quelques 520 000 démissions entre fin
2021 et début 2022 c'est pas forcément
une mauvaise chose alors est-ce qu'il y
a aussi une culture de la flemme
absolument plus d'un jeune sur deux se
dit touché par la flemme de sortir de
chez lui sans que cela ne soit considéré
comme véritablement péjoratif une brèche
dans laquelle n'a pas hésité à
s'immiscer le grand marché avec un grand
M regardez
après avoir passé une dure journée au
boulot puis à faire du sport puis faire
les devoirs le soir vous avez la flemme
nous on a la flamme cette célèbre marque
de viande n'est pas la seule à adopter
le marketing de la flemme livraison de
nourriture à domicile VTC plateforme de
streaming ils sont toujours plus
nombreux à glorifier l'art d'enfer moins
dernière victoire culturelle si j'ose
dire le petit Robert a acté en 2023
l'entrée du verbe chiller dans ses pages
Chile de l'anglais to chill prendre du
bon temps à ne rien faire vous aimez ça
aussi Mathias comme tout le monde
on va commencer par travailler donc
Jérémy Pelletier vous avez travaillé sur
cette étude vous avez constaté une
baisse de motivation chez les Français
est-ce qu'elle est vraiment plus marquée
comme essayer de le montrer Mathias chez
les jeunes elle est plus marquée en
effet chez les jeunes
ce qui est intéressant nous on a fait
cette étude là pour voir finalement les
effets de la crise sanitaire les effets
du confinement sur je dirais la carte
mentale un peu de la population et on
sait que finalement les jeunes c'est
peut-être la catégorie de la population
on en parlera peut-être qu'a été le plus
impacté par la crise sanitaire beaucoup
n'ont pas vu leur CDD renouveler
beaucoup n'ont pas vu leur contrat
d'alternance renouvelé beaucoup ont été
obligés de partir chez leurs parents
donc en effet la crise sanitaire elle a
eu un impact beaucoup plus dur c'est
chez cette jeune génération et chez les
jeunes en Île-de-France si je crois en
moi dans l'étude il y a aussi
géographiquement ça sur l'Île-de-France
c'est intéressant c'est lié aux
nouvelles habitudes prises justement
durant la crise sanitaire on sait que
les habitants d'Île-de-France et
notamment les actifs d'Île-de-France
c'est la la théorie de la population qui
a le plus expérimenté le télétravail et
donc c'est pour cette catégorie de là de
la population que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de revenir sur site de revenir
au travail parce que durant la crise
durant les confinements il y a quelque
chose de très fatigant dans nos vies à
savoir le transport les transports les
transports en commun et effectivement
quand il a refusé revenir sur site en
effet c'est cette catégorie de la
population qui ressemble le plus de
fatigue mais en effet sécher les jeunes
qu'on ressent en effet cette baisse de
motivation cette espèce de coup de mou
finalement que tout le monde a vu que
tout le monde a senti notamment depuis
la rentrée de septembre que ce soit au
travail que ce soit chez nos amis et en
effet ce petit coup de mou il a un
impact comme la très bien montré votre
journaliste sur notre rapport au travail
d'une part mais aussi sur tout un tas
d'autres activités à commencer par nos
loisirs évidemment mais aussi avec nos
relations amicales et nos relations
amoureuses par exemple on va parler de
tout ça mais un mot parce que vous dites
que vous avez fait votre étude après le
covid il y a pas que le covid il y a
tout un ensemble d'événements assez
anxiogènes aussi qu'on a subi qui
explique cette tendance oui absolument à
votre journaliste parlait de la
fragilisation psychique en gros ce qu'on
voit dans l'enquête c'est qu'on est face
à une jeune génération qui est sous
instabilité émotionnelle sous
instabilité psychique en effet on parle
de fait donc de fatigue physique mais
aussi et de fatigue psychologique et en
fait ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que évidemment il y a la crise sanitaire
mais c'est surtout l'accumulation de
tout un tas de crises depuis 2015
notamment si on fait je dirais le
décompte depuis 2015 vous avez la vague
d'attentat vous avez déjà une crise
sociale avec la réforme des retraites
vous avez évidemment la crise de gilet
jaune vous avez la guerre en Ukraine sur
fond évidemment derrière de crise
climatique et donc vous rajoutez la
crise sanitaire et donc l'accumulation
de ces crises là finalement impacte le
corps social impacte les individus on a
beaucoup parlé notamment après les
attentats vous savez de société
résiliente comme si finalement tout ça
nous glissait dessus sans impact aucun
c'est pas le cas et effectivement à
force d'accumuler ces chocs là ces chocs
traumatiques là en effet c'est un impact
sur pas la fatigue et notamment chez les
jeunes Dévi est-ce que vous vous
reconnaissez là-dedans sur cette
accumulation de crise et puis cet effet
voilà sur votre sur votre moral sur
votre motivation ouais je partage
complètement tous les toutes les crises
qui sont en train de se dérouler que ce
soit effectivement climatique sociale
économique en l'occurrence pendant le
covid on sortait entre guillemets de
d'une année voire deux années de
mobilisation énorme pour le climat de
l'environnement 2018 mars 2018 avec les
plus grosses marches jamais connu et en
l'occurrence on est rentré dans la
période covid le confinement etc et
enfin moi personnellement j'étais engagé
des associations cette sensation de
crise un peu sans fin qui s'enchaîne et
puis surtout il y a une perte aussi de
motivation de manière générale du
bénévolat donc
on a dû récupérer les charges de travail
etc et parce que tant bénévoles voilà et
donc vous avez et notamment sur les
questions climatiques environnementales
et en l'occurrence quand on a des
bénévoles en moins on a dû travailler en
plus et surtout quand on voit que il y a
peu d'impact ça a démotivé encore plus
quoi votre démotivation
bon pendant toute la période du
confinement à savoir à peu près un an
enfin je la globalise parce que le
confinement il y a eu les couvre-feu etc
ça a été beaucoup d'engagements et
je dirais que le Conseil n'arrivait plus
tard pile à la sortie en fait se rendre
compte que il y avait pas grand chose
qui avait changé surtout toutes les
questions sociales que ce soit l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes ou le
climat en l'occurrence et se rendre
compte que finalement on avait on
s'était épuisé pendant tout le
confinement pendant tout ça a créé des
campagnes de solidarité de d'engagement
tout simplement qui finalement ont pas
eu un impact énorme et là c'est la
redescente et c'est se rendre compte de
tout le travail
quand même je le sens moins comme ça
j'ai un peu j'irai un regain de
motivation lié aux mobilisation sociale
qui sont en train d'avoir lieu avec les
retraites etc mais effectivement en
sortie de covid c'était c'était
démotivant quoi et Gwenaëlle vous au
contraire vous êtes sortis de cette
crise avec avec l'idée qu'il fallait au
contraire faire des choses vivre sa vie
à fond voilà c'est presque le parti pris
inverse oui totalement parce que quand
le covid a débuté j'avais tout juste 16
ans quand on peut dire qu'on a fini je
venais juste d'avoir 18 ans et j'ai
l'impression qu'on adolescence était
parti en fumée pendant qu'il y avait
plein de choses dans le monde qui se
déroulent autour de moi alors je me suis
dit je vais vivre comme un baby-boomer
avec une conscience cette fois-ci avec
une conscience parce que j'ai pas envie
qu'on reproduise non plus les mêmes
erreurs que cette génération donc c'est
à dire que moi au contraire ça m'a
poussé à sortir à me comment dire à
observer le monde à m'intéresser avoir
moins peur finalement parce que quitte à
ce que le monde brûle moi j'aurais dansé
avant quoi oui rattraper le temps perdu
oui c'est ça totalement rattraper le
temps perdu et m'intéresser et aussi
essayer de faire ma part du Colibri
dedans de de c'est de changer les choses
à mon niveau de jeunes étudiante en
militant aussi en m'intéressant en
cultivant en fait en écoutant des
personnes qui font des études très
intéressantes et c'est comme ça je me
suis dit bon je vais je vais pouvoir
essayer de changer les choses à mon
niveau alors Daphné breton quel effet
toutes ces crises successives pour vous
ont eu sur nous et singulièrement sur
les jeunes sur le plan psychologique on
voit bon voilà de deux façons de réagir
diamétralement opposé
sur le fond c'est quand même assez
indéniable que les crises et ça je pense
que personne autour de la table viendra
contre dire mais on générer une sorte
d'anxiété généralisée quand même sur
l'avenir les conditions de vie enfin on
parle de du climat on parle de l'emploi
on parle de tous ces sujets là qui vont
toucher notamment la jeunesse qui sont
les plus concernés sur demain comment on
vit comment on travaille et il y a eu
des mots qui ont été énoncés sur le fait
de voir un impact des efforts qui sont
mobilisés sur le terrain que ce soit
dans des actions de bénévolat que ce
soit au travail qui n'ont pas fait
véritablement de résultats dans
l'entreprise c'est ce qui ressort aussi
beaucoup c'est alors vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de la notion de l'effort
et de cette perspective du coût de
l'effort qui est selon les certaines
études dit où les jeunes ne veulent plus
en tout cas faire le même effort et
subir potentiellement des impacts
physiques liés à cet effort je dirais
que c'est surtout parce que il y a pas
de résultats et de retour sur
investissement à la fois en termes de
salaire et à la fois en termes de
résultats politiques sur les ça vaut pas
le coup qu'on a un peu une déformations
puisque
finalement les résultats sont pas
forcément là on voit les réformes des
retraites qui sont annoncées alors que
des études comme
aussi sont présentées qui viennent en
total opposition avec finalement les
attentes et la dynamique de cette
jeunesse et pas que de la jeunesse parce
que un certain nombre d'actifs
s'inscrivent aussi dans cette dynamique
là donc indéniablement une angoisse
généralisée et sur les effets de crise
successives alors il y a pas que le
covid effectivement moi je remonterai à
la crise de 2008 qui a été quand même
assez
2017-2008 qui a été assez significative
sur ce que ça a pu créer au niveau de la
société notamment en France et sur cette
angoisse de l'incertitude et de l'avenir
qui a notamment été visible pour cette
nouvelle génération qui a vu leurs
parents en tout cas sur le marché de
l'emploi souffrir d'un certain nombre de
choses et des résultats sur après covid
sur des médecins qui ont effectivement
alerté sur cette dégradation de la santé
mentale puisque vous m'interrogez là
dessus
de cette jeunesse mais pas que avec des
chiffres qui sont très alarmants on les
a recités donc je vais pas les recycler
et pour une mobilisation qui reste et je
pense qu'il faut aussi souligner ça
c'est à dire que on parle d'une jeunesse
qui serait flemmarde ce terme et pour
moi assez discutable je choisirais en
discuter alors mais du coup avec des
jeunes qui restent mobilisés sur le
terrain sur des sujets enfin on voit
majoritairement le climat l'égalité
homme-femme qui sont des sujets qui
étaient peu avant saisis et peut-être
que l'individualisme il y a des moteurs
collective
mais et on le voit par ces deux exemples
mais peut-être par des canaux qui sont
pas forcément les canaux institutionnels
classiques notamment avec les réseaux
sociaux qui font qu'on réinvente aussi
de nouvelles formes de mobilisation
individuel mais avisé collective alors
on va parler de la façon dont c'est un
pacte par exemple notre rapport au
travail mais j'aimerais bien vous
entendre là-dessus sur ce thème
l'utilisation du terme flemme qui est
plutôt connoté péjorativement c'est
assumer lorsque bon ça marque les
esprits aussi je pense qu'il y a de la
communication derrière mais pourquoi
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par ce en
utilisant ce terme-là alors non c'est
pas que de la communication la note elle
s'appuie sur deux termes elle s'appuie
sur ce qu'on a appelé en effet
l'épidémie de flemme et ça c'est assumé
quand on parle d'un certain nombre de
d'activités notamment quand on parle des
loisirs quand on parle d'activité
physique quand on parle des activités
sociales quand on parle des rencontres
avec ses amis des soirées entre amis là
on assume en effet qu'il y a une montée
de flemme quand on parle du travail en
effet c'est pas le terme de flemme qu'on
a utilisé c'est le terme de fatigue et
c'est pour ça que la note des structurée
à travers ces deux termes-là le terme de
fatigue d'une part et le terme de flemme
d'autre part en effet quand on parle du
travail du nouveau rapport au travail
c'est plus en effet le terme de fatigue
de grandes fatigue généralisée de
changement de rapport au travail en
effet qu'on utilise mais le terme de
flemme en effet il est totalement assumé
d'ailleurs si la note a autant marqué si
la note a autant été diffusée c'est que
je pense que c'est un terme malgré tout
universel c'est un sentiment universel
ça parle à beaucoup de gens aux jeunes
absolument comme c'est une note qui
consacrée à tout à l'ensemble des
Français on n'est pas sur un truc anti
jeunes et voilà et d'ailleurs on voit
que finalement les jeunes sont des vieux
comme les autres par rapport à leur
flemme par rapport à ce que ce qui est
le recroquement sur sa sphère
personnelle par rapport à la difficulté
en effet qu'ils ont depuis la crise
sanitaire à sortir de chez eux pour
aller voir des amis à aller faire des
soirées le vendredi soir au lit samedi
soir en dehors de leur appartement ou en
dehors de leur maison et en effet ça
touche pas uniquement les jeunes c'est
en ça ou effectivement les jeunes ont
beaucoup de points communs avec les plus
vieux en tout cas dans le rapport à la
flemme
pour moi la notion de flemme est aussi
enfin c'est intéressant de déb sur ce
sujet là parce que la flemme est pour
moi quelque chose ou c'est un choix de
ne pas faire et je pense que que ce soit
la jeunesse mais même globalement les
individus aujourd'hui en tout cas
français non pas forcément toujours le
choix de pouvoir aller faire du sport de
pouvoir faire des choses parce que de
plus en plus de d'étudiants sont obligés
de travail c'est pas d'aujourd'hui mais
travail donc en plus pour financer leurs
études donc non pas forcément du temps
pour pouvoir faire du sport pour pouvoir
aller voir leurs amis donc il y a cette
notion de choix et de de liberté de
pouvoir ne rien faire qui est pour moi
une notion un peu de enfin c'est un luxe
quand même de pouvoir se dire on ne fait
rien on ne sort pas et donc qu'il faut
aussi rappeler et qui pour moi invite
aussi au débat dans dans ce terme qui a
été utilisé on va parler justement de ce
rapport au travail des jeunes nous
sommes avec Alexis Bertel en visio vous
êtes président de la ndrh savoir
Mont-Blanc la ndrh c'est l'association
nationale des DRH vous êtes du groupe
Pantera alors on a commencé à parler du
sujet du rapport au travail est-ce qu'il
y a un rapport particulier que vous
observez aujourd'hui des jeunes au
travail est-ce qu'il y a des jeunes qui
accordent moins d'importance au travail
que par le passé ou qui ont moins ce
goût de cette volonté de faire de
beaucoup de d'efforts comme comme on le
disait sur ce plateau
incontestablement on note un changement
en consultant l'étude de la Fondation
Jean Jaurès j'ai trouvé que un marqueur
qui était extrêmement pertinent c'était
sur l'importance du travail 60% des
répondants estimaient le travail comme
très important en 1990 et en 2021 on est
tombé à 24%. donc moitié moins que 30
ans auparavant après je pense pas que ce
soit la valeur travail qui soit attaquée
je pense pas non plus que les jeunes
soient flemmard je pense que c'est les
paradigmes qui entoure le travail donc
c'est à dire directement les conditions
de travail l'organisation du travail les
stratégies d'entreprise les valeurs
réellement on va dire défendues par les
entreprises et la place que le travail a
dans la vie des plus jeunes
et du coup est-ce que en plus
aujourd'hui alors que nous observons une
baisse du chômage ça rend encore plus
difficile l'idée de de fidéliser les
jeunes aujourd'hui qui ont déjà
peut-être un rapport un peu différent au
travail
honnêtement les entreprises elles
essaient de fidéliser de fidéliser
l'ensemble des collaborateurs quel que
soit leur âge compte tenu des
difficultés de recrutement après il est
vrai que les jeunes ont compris une
chose c'est que c'était très important
de de garantir son employabilité c'est à
dire ils ont compris qu'il ferait pas
leur carrière dans une deux ou trois
entreprises mais peut-être dans 10 voire
15 donc ils ont compris une chose c'est
qu'il fallait développer cet
embroyabilité donc suivre des formations
voilà se perfectionner dans tel ou tel
domaine et ça on constate tout
simplement par l'ancienneté moyenne des
plus jeunes qui est beaucoup plus faible
que celle des plus âgées
ils cherchent donc du coup à changer de
métier de fonctions aussi pour garantir
leur employabilité c'est ce que vous
nous dites c'est vrai on peut chercher à
acquérir de nouvelles compétences en
changeant de métier aujourd'hui
c'est ça
aujourd'hui on sait aussi une autre
chose c'est que la plupart du temps les
salariés et là je mets les jeunes les
moins jeunes dans le dans le même sac
dès lors qu'ils vont démissionner voilà
ou conduire leur carrière c'est pour
rester dans le même métier ou dans la
même filière donc par conséquent à
chaque fois qu'on constate qu'il y a des
démissions c'est pas le métier qui est
attaqué mais directement le management
voir l'entreprise donc là ça a même
directement à se questionner sur le rôle
du management la culture d'entreprise
éventuellement les valeurs la politique
RSE donc qui est menée par l'entreprise
la marque employeur aussi et tout ce qui
est lié au sens au travail
ça remet vraiment cause aujourd'hui
votre façon de fonctionner vous diriez
justement pour essayer de fidéliser
davantage ces jeunes
ça leur remet totalement en cause avant
pour caricat tirer un petit peu tu
dirais il y a 30 40 ans quand vous
managiez des équipes il fallait plutôt
s'arrêter sur le comment c'est à dire
sur le processus sur la hiérarchie sur
l'organisationnel aujourd'hui les jeunes
ce que je constate au quotidien c'est
qu'on leur dise pourquoi et pourquoi
c'est à dire quels sont les objectifs de
mon travail pour aller vers quelle
ambition
pour pour être embarqué avec un leader
qui va les amener vers voilà une
stratégie d'entreprise une culture
d'entreprise ils ont besoin aussi de
développer un sentiment d'appartenance
qui soit relativement
fort et c'est un peu contradictoire avec
l'étude mais je trouve que les
frontières des entreprises tombent peu à
peu et que maintenant quand on a un
emploi un salarié il s'attend pas
seulement à ce qu'on lui donne un
travail mais qu'on s'implique en dehors
et je prends l'exemple par exemple de la
de la mutuelle des services de concierge
lyrics certaines entreprises peuvent
mettre et ça ça contribue à la
fidélisation et à l'engagement des
salariés
et bien merci merci beaucoup pour toutes
vos explications
Alexis Bertel Gwenaëlle quel rapport
vous entretenez vous à votre travail en
pour l'instant vous avez vous travaillez
dans un restaurant parallèlement à vos
études mais est-ce que vous avez
ressenti une baisse d'implication ou de
ce genre de choses dans dans
l'entreprise ou bien pas du tout il pas
du tout d'autant que c'est pas mon
premier travail notamment cet été j'ai
travaillé en tant que recruteur donateur
pour une ONG très connue et je vois que
c'est constamment que des jeunes
demandent 25 ans qui travaillent
pourtant c'est des conditions assez
difficiles 6 jours par semaine ou toute
la journée on est debout est-ce que vous
voulez bien nous donner 10 euros s'il
vous plaît c'est très dur mais je vois
que c'est globalement que des jeunes en
fait qui sont qui sont très motivés et
la motivation aussi alimentaire
forcément
bien sûr oui c'est c'est lié à
l'alimentaire mais je vois beaucoup chez
les jeunes que ça recherche beaucoup de
travail on recherche tout du travail
mais ça a beaucoup plus être dans
l'ordre de j'ai envie de faire un
travail mais qui me parle c'est à dire
que même si c'est juste un travail
étudiant ça me parle là typiquement
c'était bon cette ONG me parle je vais
travailler pour elle même si c'est comme
une recherche de sens il y a toujours
une recherche de sens même si c'est
juste pour se nourrir ou pour payer son
loyer étudiant donc je trouve qu'il y a
pas vraiment une baisse de motivation au
travail même je vais dans les fast food
c'est toujours des jeunes qui qui nous
servent globalement donc je pense que
la jeunesse n'est pas si fragile que ça
dans le travail et saviez-vous que vous
êtes actuellement en alternance quel
rapport vous entretenez à votre votre
travail quelle part ça occupe aussi dans
votre vie est-ce que vous reconnaissez
un peu dans ce qu'on disait c'est à dire
j'ai pas non plus envie de sacrifier ma
vie au travail dans quel rapport
êtes-vous effectivement je suis plutôt
de ceux qui ont pas du tout envie de
sacrifier leur vie au travail
l'idéal c'est d'avoir un travail qui a
du sens évidemment tout le monde peut
pas se le permettre
[Musique]
c'est la grande bascule la sacralisation
de l'effort n'est plus dans l'air du
temps quand l'ambition est en revanche
clairement assumée et valorisée ce qui
m'intéresse aussi c'est la dimension
d'ambition aujourd'hui mais c'est pas
parce que on a un rapport différent
travail qu'on a pas cette ambition quand
même de réussir mais mais pas parler
même bien ouais absolument les jeunes
dans l'enquête ils se définissent comme
des travailleurs qu'on veut leur
demander est-ce que vous vous sentez
travailleur est-ce que vous considérez
si il faut vous auto-évaluer est-ce que
vous considérez comme un travailleur
comme un bosseur une grande majorité des
jeunes se considère en effet comme des
bosseurs il se considère aussi beaucoup
comme des ambitieux donc pour le coup
ambitieux travailleur par contre en
effet quand vous leur demandez mais
est-ce que gagner suppose de faire des
sacrifices est-ce qu'il faut souffrir
pour réussir vous avez encore une grande
majorité de la population qui est
d'accord avec cette idée là avec cette
affirmation là mais en effet les jeunes
pour le coup ont perdu je dirais la
dimension sacrificielle du travail alors
on peut considérer que c'est une bonne
chose et d'ailleurs c'est sans doute une
bonne chose mais ça c'est aussi l'effet
en effet vous avez raison de citer la
crise de 2008 vous avez beaucoup de
jeunes en effet qui avec la crise de
2008 ont vu leurs parents se faire
licencier se faire virer se faire
dégager des entreprises du jour au
lendemain après 20 ans ou 30 ans de bon
Éloïse et finalement vous avez une
partie des jeunes qui depuis ce
moment-là se disent mais finalement
pourquoi ça sert à quoi ça sert de se
donner autant au travail
émotionnellement passionnellement
psychiquement si en gros à la première
crise venue de toute façon tous les
efforts que j'aurais fait n'auront aucun
impact et je ne verrai jamais finalement
le fruit de mes efforts donc en effet il
y a un rééquilibrage
accélérer notamment par la crise
sanitaire entre ce que je donne à
l'entreprise et ce que j'en reçois le
mot de la fin pour vous sur cette partie
effectivement sur et bien cette idée que
les jeunes ne veulent plus sacrifier
leur vie au travail et qui apparaît
clairement aujourd'hui alors un chiffre
pour commencer c'est 21 % des arrêts
maladie pour troubles psychiques et
aujourd'hui le deuxième motif d'arrêt
des arrêts malades derrière les maladies
ordinaires c'est la première fois en
plusieurs décennies qui a eu ce
renversement 21% de ses arrêts
concernent les jeunes donc à dire que
les jeunes n'ont plus envie de se
sacrifier pour le travail dans les faits
c'est ce qu'ils aimeraient dans les
faits en réalité
souffre déjà du travail tu travailles
donc ça il faut bien de l'avoir en tête
et il faut mettre en perspective pour
moi cet aspect de la question du sens et
de la place du travail également avec le
fait que pendant le confinement
notamment on s'est aperçu que le travail
prenait beaucoup de place qu'on est venu
réinterroger cette place du travail et
ça je pense que c'est quelque chose de
très positif du temps qu'on y consacre
il faut aussi prendre en compte le fait
que
aujourd'hui sur cette question de on en
a parlé tout à l'heure mais de la grande
démission ou de cette démotivation il y
a aussi l'aspect des conditions de
travail de leur dégradation qui à mettre
en lien avec le phénomène de
financiarisation qui a eu un impact
considérable sur la standardisation du
travail sur des objectifs chiffrés qui
sont totalement déconnectés du travail
et de la notion de qualité de travail en
fait le sens qu'on trouve dans le
travail tout à fait un sens qui n'est
plus recherché des entreprises qui même
si elles se disent en tout cas à se
réinterroger sur comment fidéliser les
travailleurs et notamment les jeunes qui
ne se mettent pas à réfléchir sur ces
conditions de travail et d'emploi
véritablement moi je j'interviens dans
les entreprises également et je ne
perçois pas ce renversement des
politiques de GPE de gestion des emplois
et des compétences de des politiques sur
la place du des conditions de travail
donc c'est voilà on pourrait en parler
de longues heures et pas forcément de
temps mais cette place du travail est
pour moi enfin pour finir sur une autre
active le de réinterroger la place du
travail dans nos vies et pour moi
quelque chose qui est très intéressant
et qu'il faudrait en tout cas investir
pour que la santé mentale décide des
individus d'une manière générale
s'améliore voilà une piste de réflexion
merci beaucoup Daphné breton pour votre
participation à cette émission on a
beaucoup parlé du travail on va aussi
parler bien de la vie privée la vie
privée qui est gagnée aujourd'hui par la
révolution numérique qui a créé elle
aussi une nouvelle économie une économie
de la flemme dont le boom des livraisons
à domicile et l'illustration on peut se
faire livrer n'importe quel objet en
moins de 24 heures aujourd'hui on peut
se faire livrer son repas tout préparé
et puis un nouvel acteur sur le créneau
et bien ce sont les applis de livraison
de courses comme flink qui s'est lancé
sur ce marché qui reste aujourd'hui ni
chien plutôt là encore jeune
urbaine la Cécile Sixto était allé voir
comment ces nouveaux venus du Quick
commerce fonctionne regardez
des livreurs en rose et bleu si vous
habitez dans une grande ville vous les
avez certainement croisés sur leur vélo
il pour flink une start-up
nouveau genre née en 2020 en Allemagne
qui promet du Quick commerce la
livraison de vos courses en moins de 15
minutes une liste de courses un clic et
la commande arrive dans cette entreprise
où on s'active pour aller le plus vite
possible une fois que c'est arrivé sur
ce système là donc c'est
envoyé sur cet appareil pour le
préparateur de commande qui lui ensuite
va préparer la commande donc dans les
rayons de façon optimisée c'est à dire
que c'est l'appareil qui va lui dire
dans quel ordre choisir ses produits et
ça va lui permettre de faire seulement
un aller-retour pour pas perdre de temps
à faire des allers-retours lorsqu'il
prépare marquage au sol organisation
rationalisée des produits chariots à
roulettes tout est fait pour gagner du
temps
marketing de l'application et Lise Leroy
la rapidité est oui des consommateurs
habitués depuis le covid a commandé via
des applis aujourd'hui on est dans une
société où tout va très vite les gens
sont en recherche constante de
d'optimisation de leur temps d'avoir
plus de temps libre et en fait
aujourd'hui le Quick commerce permet une
flexibilité une agilité et une
spontanéité qui permet aux gens d'éviter
certaines tâches donc typiquement aller
en magasin pour faire les courses et
donc on leur redonne du temps libre tout
en réduisant leur stress dans ces
magasins fantômes près de 2000 produits
sont stockés prêts à être embarqués par
les livreurs
et voilà tu peux y aller une quinzaine
d'entreprises comme flics ont fait leur
apparition ces deux dernières années
mais elle reste encore méconnue en 2021
seul 2,3% des Français ont fait appel à
ses services pour la majorité jeune et
périurbain dans les rues de la capitale
les avis des jeunes sur ses applis sont
partagés si ça m'évite de faire 30
minutes 40 minutes de marche et que je
peux faire autre chose à la place
pourquoi pas je veux dire si je suis
plus productif chez moi à faire autre
chose au lieu de perdre mon temps à
aller puis venir pour juste chercher la
farine je pense que oui j'utiliserai
cette application j'essaie de limiter
notamment avec tout ce qu'on raconte sur
la condition la précarité de tous ces
travailleurs-là mais sur malhonnête de
dire que je compte plus du tout donc
j'essaie de me restreindre au moment je
pense que c'est à ce côté facilité
que on avait déjà auparavant sur la
livraison et comme maintenant on peut
tout avoir apporté d'un clic et ben il y
a des gens ils préfèrent faire ça plutôt
que se déplacer et d'être dans le froid
avec ses 175 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires le Quick commerce certains
marchés de niche par rapport aux
livraison de repas à domicile ou encore
Amazon qui a réalisé en 2021 un chiffre
d'affaires de 9 milliards d'euros et
j'accueille sur ce plateau Vincent
kochbert bonjour vous êtes journaliste
et vous êtes l'auteur du livre la
civilisation du cocon un livre dans
lequel vous citez en introduction une
nouvelle de science-fiction qui
s'appelle la machine s'arrête qui date
de 1909 qui parle de gens qui vivent
désormais dans des appartements bulles
quand on nous regarde aujourd'hui vous
dites bon bah la fiction a rejoint la
réalité la réalité a rejoint la fiction
surtout la science-fiction en tout cas
où la réalité a rejoint la
science-fiction ça c'est sûr mais voilà
donc en fait il y avait cette il y avait
cette vision là d'un monde qui allait
être de plus en plus cloisonnée et c'est
un monde en fait que mon expérimente
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il y avait
quelque chose d'assez saisissant dans le
parallèle de cette de cette petite
nouvelle là et le monde qu'on est en
train de vivre mais voilà en fait pour
expliquer un petit peu tout ça c'est
qu'en fait on est dans un phénomène
avant même la flemme en fait un
phénomène de grande domiciliation ça
c'est quelque chose qui a commencé en
fait dès le début des années 2000 milieu
des années 2000 on a commencé à
on a commencé à domicilier la culture on
a commencé à domicilié à la consommation
on a même domicilié les relations
humaines avec les sites de rencontres et
infinet on a aussi domicilié le travail
donc en fait c'est une posture ou qu'on
a pu déjà même observer dès la fin des
années 80 en fait qui était des années
économiquement assez dur ou même la
figure pop c'était celle du Golden Boy
en fait on était dans des années de
réussite de chic de frimes et on a pu
observer dès la fin des années 80 en
fait déjà un repli domestique qui avait
lieu d'abord chez les classes populaires
et qui petit à petit dans les années 90
on a commencé à parler de cocooning mais
bon là les services de livraison étaient
pas encore tout à fait au point il y
avait en livrer des pizzas mais c'était
vraiment la seule chose qu'on livrait et
en fait avec la numérisation du monde et
donc le développement d'Internet je vois
tout simplement on a pu finalement avoir
cette perspective de faire venir le
monde à nous entièrement et de quelque
part ne plus avoir ne plus avoir
d'excuses en fait d'aller le conquérir
donc c'est c'est une posture qui a été
radicalisée évidemment avec le avec le
confinement parce qu'on a vécu vraiment
une hystérisation finalement de cette
une obligation quelque part d'être dans
cette posture là et chez certaines
personnes cette rupture du continent de
temporel a créé une sorte de
désenchantement de difficulté finalement
de renouer avec la vie avec la vie
extérieure de l'extérieur voilà avec une
altérité c'est en fait c'est le confort
la sécurité parce que c'est ça la
civilisation du coca c'est une
civilisation qui est en recherche de
confort de sécurité et d'entre soi de
gens qui nous ressemblent de communauté
un peu miroir et donc quelque part plus
on est un peu le grand ordonnateur de
son petit membre depuis chez soi plus là
et qu'on met à la réalité à distance
parce qu'on fait venir la réalité plus
elle va nous sembler en fait rugueuse
compliquée et on voyait bien en fait des
études à la sortie du premier
confinement les gens n'avaient pas une
folle envie de renouer en fait avec
l'altérité il y en a même quelques-uns
qui étaient en train de se dire mince je
regrette quelque part ce début de
confinement j'étais vécu ma meilleure
vie pendant le confinement ils étaient
en fait ils étaient à la tête de leur
petite citadelle et à un moment donné il
pouvait retracer des contours aussi du
temps de leur vie ils ont l'impression
en fait d'avoir un peu revu d'avoir une
sorte de respiration mais cette
respiration là pour reprendre la course
c'est un peu compliqué derrière
l'emblème de tout ça sont bien sûr bien
toutes ces applis qui se sont
développées ce business cette économie
de la flemme est-ce que vous les
utilisez beaucoup d'avis Gwenaëlle je
dirais pas beaucoup je sais pas mais je
les utilisais quand il y a des promos
surtout parce que c'est une question
financière
sinon peu quand tu en as pas et
globalement plus ça plus des applis de
VTC à cause des transports en commun à
Paris que
vous dites c'est pas bien il vaut pas
que j'utilise
un petit peu quand on parle du coup
environnemental quand on parle du
rapport que ça
surtout le coup social en fait avec le
traitement des livreurs mais à côté de
ça là vous parliez de flink sur sur le
petit reportage il y a d'autres
applications qui essayent en
l'occurrence de vraiment salarié leur
leur livreur et de leur donner des
conditions de travail je fais pas les
citer du coup mais j'utilise plus ces
applications là qui proposent aussi des
plats beaucoup plus végétariens vegan
que les applications qui peuvent être
proposées sur Flint
aussi hypocrite que de dire que je les
utilise jamais je pense que ça se joue
plutôt en crise existentielle donc
toutes les deux mois si j'ai vraiment
envie de m'enfermer dans ma tour
d'ivoire là je vais pas mettre de
commander mais sinon j'ai quand même de
du mal à ce qu'on vient de me livrer des
choses chez moi ou qu'on me transporte
d'un point à un autre enfin moi je vois
ça vraiment comme un esclavagisme
moderne et puis en plus ça enlève un peu
tout le tout le goût du hasard parce que
comme vous disiez on ramène le monde
chez nous mais enfin où est le hasard où
elles sont les rencontres un peu
farfelues mauvaises comme bonne mais ce
qui forge un peu les anecdotes de la vie
et je trouve que ça enlève tout ce en
fait
ça enlève tout ça et du coup tout
devient un peu morose et on se gangrène
dedans et je trouve ça un peu une
intéressante alors nous sommes à présent
en visio avec Davian MAE bonjour bonjour
Davian alors vous avez vous 19 ans vous
vivez à Nantes vous êtes en alternance
actuellement BTS Communication et au CHU
de Nantes et vous le dites vous-même
vous êtes un consommateur excessif des
applications de livraison alors
qu'est-ce que vous utilisez et un peu à
quelle fréquence
alors moi c'est plus pour par exemple
mes cours je par exemple je n'ai pas de
permis de conduire et donc c'est
toujours plus facile de se faire livrer
ses courses chez soi avec des magasins
qui sont plus en périphérie de la ville
et qui utilisent des applications comme
vous en parliez précédemment des
applications on peut se faire livrer par
des particuliers c'est course ça je le
fais environ une fois par mois après il
y a des applications de livraison de de
fast food ou de restaurants là je le
fais plus 2 à 3 fois par semaine c'est
souvent quand il y a des amis chez soi
c'est toujours mieux enfin c'est
toujours plus simple du moins pour quand
on reçoit des amis chez soi du coup vous
êtes beaucoup dans votre groupe d'amis
du coup à utiliser ce type d'appli et
vous aimez mieux cela plutôt que je sais
pas de faire la cuisine peut-être dans
des logements étudiants comment ça se
passe
pas forcément après évidemment on est
étudiant et donc dans un quand on a
souvent un petit studio c'est toujours
plus compliqué de faire de la grande
cuisine après on privilégie au maximum
de like parce que sur les applications
et tout ça c'est souvent pas trop de la
cuisine saine mais en tout cas en
privilégie au maximum mais c'est vrai
que quand on a des amis on a toujours
moins de temps de faire à manger quand
on est étudiant donc c'est plus simple
et c'est apporter de soi et malgré le
coup que ça représente notamment pour
une bourse étudiante comment est-ce que
vous organisez au niveau de votre budget
alors pour ma part du coup je suis
alternant donc c'est je suis pas
étudiant comme classique avec des
revenus donc c'est toujours plus facile
entre guillemets mais c'est vrai que
pour les étudiants c'est compliqué et
donc il faut savoir aussi se restreindre
quand on est étudiant il y a une chose
qui m'a marqué aussi que vous avez
raconté dans votre prime interview c'est
que par exemple il y avait aussi c'était
votre usage de ses applis c'est aussi
marqué par une certaine crainte de
l'insécurité donc vous vivez à Nantes et
vous dites à partir de une certaine
heure vous préférez ne pas être dehors
c'est cela
c'est vrai que quand il se fait tard
après 22h en général c'est toujours plus
compliqué de rentrer chez soi notamment
comme par exemple avec les transports en
commun et donc c'est vrai que ça
m'arrive de prendre des applications de
de VTC pour rentrer chez soi ou alors
même pour se faire livrer à manger quand
il est un peu plus tard que de prendre
les transports pour aller chercher à
manger c'est toujours plus rassurant de
l'avoir en bas de chez soi et de ne pas
avoir à sortir dans la ville alors vous
jugez vous même comme un consommateur
excessif est-ce que ça veut dire que
vous ressentez aussi une forme de
culpabilité dont je parlais à l'instant
quand vous utilisez ce type d'appli
oui parce que c'est pas je dirais pas
que c'est soit une bonne pratique parce
qu'évidemment quand on commande par
exemple sur les gens comme Amazon
on préférerait commander dans des
commerces aller dans les commerces de
proximité c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qu'on doit faire aussi c'est moi
par exemple j'essaye de privilégier au
maximum quand j'ai besoin d'aller
chercher un livre par exemple je
privilégie la librairie du coin de la
rue plutôt que plutôt que les
applications merci merci beaucoup
d'avion pour votre votre témoignage
Jérémy Pelletier on voit aussi que l'une
des raisons certainement pour lesquelles
les jeunes ont pu recours à ses applis
c'est que c'est vraiment quelque chose
de générationnel aussi c'est ce que vous
observez ouais c'est quelque chose de
générationnel je trouve qu'il y a très
intéressant dans le propos c'est à quel
point finalement l'extérieur l'espace
public le dehors est devenu insécurisant
et devenu flippant et on le voit
beaucoup notamment sur la question des
sorties famille vous aviez évoqué tout à
l'heure mon livre et en effet ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que vous voyez
depuis un certain nombre d'années depuis
10 ans maintenant et c'est un élément
qui est accéléré en effet par la crise
sanitaire c'est un développement de ce
qu'on pourrait appeler la fête à la
maison la fête à la maison que ce soit
en appartement ou que ce soit dans une
maison et d'ailleurs c'est la même chose
on retrouve les mêmes tendances en
province que dans les grandes villes on
retrouve la même tendance dans les
honorales que dans les grandes villes
donc c'est quelque chose qui touche tous
les jeunes tout les tous les les
territoires et en effet la fête à la
maison c'est la fête de la fin du hasard
c'est la fête de la fin de l'aléatoire
et c'est en ça ou l'économie de la
flemme dont on parle depuis tout à
l'heure en fait elle joue aussi beaucoup
sur nos comportements sur nos habitudes
parce que les applications ça nous
habituent à une société sur mesure ça
nous habitué finalement à tout contrôler
en permanence à avoir absolument tout ce
que l'on veut en un clic de façon
immédiate et en effet la fête à la
maison c'est la fête de la fin du hasard
on contrôle les gens qui sont à la
maison on contrôle le fil de la soirée
on contrôle la musique qu'on nous passe
c'est très frappé de voir quand je
travaillais un peu sur le sujet que
quand vous allez interroger des jeunes
sur les raisons pour laquelle ils ne
vont plus en boîte de nuit vous avez une
partie que vous dit mais vous savez en
boîte de nuit on nous passe de la
musique qu'on n'aime pas forcément alors
que chez nous au moins on est notre
propre DJ c'est nous qui mesurerons
la musique Berne absolument aujourd'hui
notamment à après le covid mais voilà
absolument c'était déjà le cas avant le
covid c'est accélérer notamment depuis
le covid et donc il y a cet élément là
qui est lié à la société du sur-mesure
la société du contrôle et aussi pour
faire le lien l'insécurité de l'espace
public en tout cas l'insécurité ressenti
pardon quand à l'espace public les
jeunes femmes que j'interrogeais au
moment de ce livre là disait beaucoup
vous savez nous on ne sort plus dans les
bars on ne sort plus en boîte et on
préfère faire la fête chez nous dans
l'appartement dans la maison parce qu'en
fait on a peur de se faire embêter on a
peur de se faire agresser on a peur de
tomber en effet sur des mauvaises
personnes absolument aujourd'hui quand
on quand on parle de boîte de nuit c'est
ce qu'on a le plus dans les médias
Vincent Kobe vous êtes d'accord à
l'extérieur elle est davantage vu
aujourd'hui comme comme agresseur mais
moi ce qui marque aussi c'est que
j'ai l'impression que par exemple
aujourd'hui les parents ne laissent plus
du tout autant leurs enfants dehors et
forcément ça doit modifier les
comportements de ceux qui deviennent
jeunes ensuite complètement ben c'est un
mouvement qui est qui germe depuis très
très longtemps depuis plusieurs
générations il y a une étude très
intéressante qui avait été fait par un
psychologue anglais en fait qui avait
essayé de voir dans une même famille en
fait dans une même lignée qu'est-ce qui
avait le droit de faire en fait l'enfant
que soit un garçon ou une fille quand il
avait 10 ans donc il y avait l'arrière
arrière-grand-père lui quand il avait 10
ans il avait le droit d'aller à 20 km
elle est chasser dans un parc à côté et
80 ans après son petit petit-fils lui a
le droit d'évoluer à 150 mètres autour
de la maison pareil dans les années fin
des années 70 milieu des années 70 il y
avait 80% des CM2 qui allaient eux-mêmes
en fait à l'école à pied sans leurs
parents aujourd'hui c'est le contraire
c'est 20% qui va à pied donc en fait
cette civilisation aussi on est dans une
perspective de repli qui est à la fois
psychique mais à la fois physique et qui
fait qu'à la fin aussi on ce grand
prince ce grand principe qu'on a vu
apparaître dans les années 90 qui est le
principe de sécurité qui était qui était
apparu avec la suite du Sommet de Rio
parce le principe de sécurité là ce
principe de prévoyance quelque part on
l'a appliqué à tous les champs de notre
vie on l'a appliqué au niveau
existentiel au niveau professionnel au
niveau amoureux et au niveau spatial
aussi donc l'autre nous paraît de plus
en plus lointain et bon ça on commence à
le connaître ce chiffre là mais on est
plus de 70 % en France à dire on se
méfie jamais assez de l'autre donc on
est une toute petite minorité à croire
que l'altérité ne nous voit pas du mal
de manière inhérente quoi alors son
petit
petit-fils comme vous dites aujourd'hui
et bien en tout cas vous le dis à
l'instant la fête est finie une
expérimente plus tellement la fièvre du
samedi mais plutôt le canap du vendredi
et c'est ce que vous disiez Pascal est
belle vous avez consacré l'an dernier
une étude pour le Crédoc vendredi soir
idéal des Français c'est quoi le
vendredi soir idéal des Français
aujourd'hui
alors en effet ça a été fait vraiment à
la même époque de l'année au mois de
février et ce qui est caractéristique
c'est vraiment cette question de
préférer le cocooning d'être sur son
canapé ou en couple à manger des pizzas
devant la télé c'est 50% des français
qui vont répondre ça plus ensuite on a
quand même une partie de la population
15% qui pense à sortir et une chose un
peu plus surprenante qui sont ceux qui
ont plutôt des tâches domestiques à
faire ça paraissait pas évident comme ça
mais qui vont faire leurs courses le
vendredi pour libérer leur samedi mais
aussi faire le ménage et ça c'est pour
des populations qui ont en effet moins
de moyens que les autres donc ce qu'on
peut constater aujourd'hui c'est
vendredi soir peut-être pas idéal mais
en tout cas habituel quoi pour certains
pour beaucoup de fruits alors pour eux
idéal c'est à dire qu'on est on se
projette souvent nous-mêmes avec nos
propres façons de vivre mais on peut se
mettre à la place de certaines autres
personnes qui peuvent vivre bien en fait
la tâche domestique on est on n'est pas
tous logés à la même enseigne et ça peut
donner il y a des gens que à qui ça fait
plaisir c'est pas forcément
on peut aussi interpréter comme ça mais
ce qu'il y a c'est qu'en effet ce qui
est typique du moment donné et ce qui a
dû changer par rapport à cette étudiant
non c'est vraiment la question de se
retrouver ensemble c'est que je suis
assez d'accord pour dire que pendant le
covid on était vraiment replié sur soi
et c'était difficile pour certains de
sortir de retrouver les autres mais ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
cherche quand même de plus en plus
d'occasions pour se retrouver avec les
autres et les sorties ont quand même
beaucoup repris et on est plus quand
même dans dans un monde où on a plus
envie de croiser l'extérieur on est on a
quand même toute une partie de la
jeunesse qui sort beaucoup la
restauration n'a jamais aussi bien
fonctionné donc on
quand même de plus en plus et c'est vrai
que dans cette étude ce qui était
intéressant c'est que en France leur
repas le lieu où on mange c'est un
moment privilégié et Capri plus de place
en fait c'est que l'alimentation a
retrouvé des lettres de noblesse
notamment parce que pendant ces périodes
de confinement et il nous restait que ça
à faire et les jeunes qui étaient un
petit peu détachés finalement se sont
remis à faire la cuisine c'est des
choses qui reviennent en ce moment
évidemment dans un contexte d'inflation
donc n'oublions pas quand même que les
êtres humains ont besoin de rencontrer
des gens de rencontrer des gens
différents donc même si on a redécouvert
la famille et on se retrouvait à deux
sur un canapé le mot emblématique
c'était le plaid qui est revenu ces
derniers mois avec le froid et avec le
prix de l'énergie il y a quand même un
besoin d'aller à l'extérieur et de voir
des individus différents et qui
je vois dans tout un tas d'activités de
loisirs si on revient sur la question
des jeunes sur laquelle nous sommes
centrés aujourd'hui ce qui j'ai trouvé
intéressant dans votre étude c'est qu'il
y avait pas les mêmes attentes chez les
18 24 chez les 25 34 chez les 18 24 il y
a encore le goût de la fête et les 25 34
au contraire c'est la belle du canapé et
des jeux vidéo ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ça
oui alors je crois que c'est vraiment
lié aussi que le devis c'est à dire que
les 27 34 qui sont beaucoup plus souvent
en couple et finalement on se suffit à
deux alors que les 18 24 ils sont
beaucoup plus fréquemment seul et ils
sont encore dans une phase où ils ont
besoin de rencontrer du monde en fait il
y a une différence qu'on observe en ce
moment qui est quand même un petit peu
générationnel c'est que les 18 24 ans
sont aussi ceux qui ont le plus souffert
du covid les 27 4 mois parce qu'en fait
ils étaient actifs ils ont pu travailler
alors que les 18 24 ils étaient pour la
plupart étudiants et ils étaient tout
tout à distance donc il y a quand même
des choses à regarder à l'avenir on sent
qu'il y a des différences en fait entre
les 18 24 et les 25 34 notamment les 18
24 sont moins dans dans le moule
d'accepter les changements climatiques
dans ils ont un petit peu envie de vivre
en fait et on sent ça très fortement
dans la consommation
en fait par exemple ils achètent
beaucoup ils ont des étages un peu plus
fébrile que ce qu'on observer d'ailleurs
il y a deux ans où il y a un an et sans
doute qu'ils ont des choses à rattraper
et bien merci merci beaucoup Pascal est
belle pour tous vos éclairages pour
conclure j'aimerais bien savoir vous
c'est quoi votre vendredi soir idéal
Gwenaëlle vous vous trouvez vous êtes
dans la tranche ou plutôt au goût de la
fête pour l'instant oui plutôt oui
[Musique]
sur idéal je dirais un film de Godard à
la Cinémathèque
un verre pour débriefer puis après on va
en boîte jusqu'à 5h ah voilà bon donc
à l'ancienne j'allais dire des vies
c'est quoi votre vendredi soir idéal un
peu dans la même idée un before à la
maison et puis une soirée bien arrosée
après en soirée en boîte et ça vous
arrive encore beaucoup voilà vous aimez
vous êtes vous êtes pas tant marqué
parce qu'on disait quand même sur cette
nouvelle cet appel du canapé du week-end
le canapé dans les feuilles étudiants
façon
canapé ouais et ben voilà et alors et
vous parce que en fait on peut aussi
vous demander vous c'est quoi votre
histoire idéale vous avez encore le
droit de faire c'est une soirée imprévue
c'est en vente histoire qui finalement
ne se passe pas comme finalement il
était prévu qu'il se passe c'est un
vendredi soir ou effectivement il y a
une fête de hasard il y a une part
d'aléatoire il y a une part de rencontre
il y a une part de lieux découvert que
vous n'avez dans lesquelles vous n'étiez
pas censé aller voilà c'est un vendredi
soir qui vous permet de raconter des
choses en fait le lendemain et en fait
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
si on passe toujours à faire la même
chose si finalement on a une forme
d'habitude un peu morose on a plus rien
à raconter derrière donc faut faire faut
avoir des vendredis soirs qui vous
permettent de raconter des choses le
lendemain et pour pouvoir raconter les
choses de lendemain faut pas passer son
vendredi soir le filmer parce que sinon
vous n'avez rien à raconter le lendemain
pour conclure c'est quoi vous votre
vendredi soir idéal oui bah pareil je
sors moi c'est plus pour les concerts
mais
voilà
un peu de mal à grandir c'est peut-être
pour ça mais continuez voilà je continue
aussi à l'appel de l'extérieur reste
assez fort il y a pas de mal à se faire
du bien merci beaucoup à tous les quatre
d'être venu dans cette émission merci
beaucoup à vous de l'avoir suivi
rendez-vous le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro d'avoir 20 ans
[Musique]